[Music] we've seen Kris Jenner do the mannequin challenge the Backstreet Boys did the Harlem shake but the latest viral dance craze that has celebrities hooked Drake's in my feelings challenge that's comedian choker he started the trend when he posted that video to Instagram on June 29th ever since our favorite celebrities can't seem to stop dancing [Music] Ciara and husband Russell Wilson got down on their honeymoon in South Africa while fellow R&B singer Tinashe got creative in the pool with her girlfriends DJ Khaled made it a family affair before busting a move near the beach but in only is Billy stead of Graham yes we got a family sterling K Brown and Susan caliche Watson are busy filming this is us but never too busy to remind us why we love them so darn much [Music]